[Music]
I am a student in bioinformatics and
I work mainly with genetic data
and my goal would be to be
able to use this data
to advance personalized medicine to
better understand diseases
my name is camille richard bélanger
for me the  science or activists
but I am developing
optimization algorithms whose goal is to
maximize performance sultane magnet
in search of the optimum and
I would like to deploy her approaches in
there in adaptive clinical trials my
name is audrey durand is for  me
science is extra working in learning
an automaton and would there be
felt circles stand by being worked in
can postpone our minimal chances
my project aims to improve an
important component of the
supply chain to
canadian companies and  the goal is to minimize
the bridges while satisfying at best
lyon my name is mirabel and the asim
for me is perseverance  e
learning presentation for all the
[Music]
work on the development
of algorithms to accelerate the
discovery of our mitterrands and of
course the objective is to release
all our little models,
it's nice the rats but in the real world
life to help real people and
have a pact that calls me rima either
it is for me science it
is something that we appropriate
[Music]